ambassador the open letter sent from
your country to South Korea early this
month
talks about foreign forces being wholly
to blame for the tragic and disgraceful
history of the foot Korean nation I take
it you mean American forces can there be
peace on the Korean Peninsula as long as
American forces remain in the South in
your opinion well as long as the United
States obstructs the unification of the
country as well as rom you know stage B
makes the Korean Peninsula tense it is
not helpful you know for the United
States remaining South Korean you know
as you know the Korean nation is a
homogenous nation with the same plan
which has really four century for all
for all for a long time creating one
culture and one nation but it has been
split and divided by the United States
and United States you know Chris the
station tense all the time by bringing
in the military equipment and obstructs
the peace and security on the Korean
Peninsula by pursuing the hostile policy
and particularly by threatening the deep
her career with nuclear weapons so I
don't think the United States is harmful
unless it abandons its hostile policy
against the deeper Korea and gives up
the military threat whether it is
conventional or whether it is a nuclear
but of course South Korea and the United
States will see your country as the
threat that's the problem I mean you
could work together where it is the
electorate is unilateral insistence you
know if you leave look into the Korean
Peninsula
you know the main question is nuclear
issue right well of course deeper Korea
is yep we have a nuclear deterrent but
you should understand why the deeper
Korea had chosen the way of having a
nuclear deterrent you know deep her
career has been under the nuclear threat
by the United States from the early
1950s in during the war in the in the
1950 the United States threatened that
dilled used nuclear bombs and in 1950s
they began to bring all the nuclear
weapons into South Korea and you
remember all the successive presidents
of the United States claimed that they
would use all options in case of a
contingency on the Korean Peninsula not
excluding the nuclear weapons this is
the this is the policy and the United
States in action they staged the nuclear
war exercises the annual against deeper
Korea
so deeper Korea had no option but to
have the nuclear deterrent in order to
defend the sovereignty of the country
and in order to save the security and
peace on the Korean Peninsula as well as
the live lives of the people so our
house is just and the insistent is wrong
if you know there is no military a
nuclear threat it's not available from
the United States then the you know and
and also the hostile policy of the
United States which can't withdrawn then
the it is a it is another matter
so the United States removed the nuclear
threat or at least the nuclear threats
as your country sees it Pyongyang would
be willing to denuclearize to be willing
to get rid of its nuclear weapons with
it well if the United States gives up
it's a hostile power
see against the dipper Korea and did it
does not threat that he threatened the
deep her career with nuclear reference
then the you know the relations between
the between the two countries could
become normalized in that case all the
issues can be resolved smoothly I mean
when when I say all the issues means all
this is concerned by each side will be
solved smoothly but America says that if
they are Gant went to talks again can
resume the nuclear talks then your
country must stop producing more nuclear
weapons it so country prepared to do
that
in order to take the first step towards
talks well you are saying about the
preconditions to the forward by the
United States the United States wants
the deeper Korea to do action to pop to
fulfill its obligation first in action
they said right you know that you know
you know it is peace they asked us to
show the sincerity which we all the time
so the sincerity but we cannot you know
perform our obligations first you know
as you remember September 19th joint
statement which was a read upon in in
the six-party talks predicted how does
it describe that described Mr described
there pinpoints that the United States
has a United States commitment to
abandon the hostile policy towards the
deeper Korea and they committed that
they do not read the deeper Korea by
military action whether it is you know
conventional or by or nuclear nuclear
war they didn't they didn't do there
they didn't to perform their own
obligations but they won't dig her
career to fulfill our obligations first
this is a precondition so the six-party
talks
they are talking about the resumption of
the six-party talks they said in order
for the six-party talks to be resumed
deeper Korea should move forced as you
say but it is you know this is a
dialogue part we are dialogue partners
and dialogue partners should do what
they have committed already the United
States didn't do anything what what they
should do while demanding deeper Korea
should do first so it is unreasonable
that is why we cannot accept it one a
much this open letter is pre-empting an
event that will happen next month in
February the joint military exercises
between the south of the peninsula South
Korea and the United States yes if those
exercises go ahead will North Korea
respond I do not like it is wise to
predict the consequence of the event
right so it is not a matter [ __ ] agency
what is important is is is that the good
cause of the tension should be removed
this is more important we have to think
about how to remove the cause of the
tension on the Korean Peninsula the
these are annual exercises on this
happen every year
no weapons have been fired towards your
country so there's no reason to assume
that they'll be fired this year the
continued military exercises under the
pretext of a annual and it is decisive
in Asia sort of thing but if you look
into the scale and contents of the
military exercises they are planning to
stage you can understand this is just
for aggression against the deeper Korea
you know all thousands hundreds of
thousands of troops are scheduled to
mobilize the troops you know the the US
troops in South Korea of course and the
South Korean
military as well as the US troops that
are stationed in in the mainland Pacific
and in Japan all of them are involved
are scheduled to involved in that
military exercises and if you're looking
to the last year's key resolve and no
evil found military sizes they brought
in nuclear equipments including static
static bumbles b-52 bombers yeah and
then this treacherous stealth Xterra
fighters a and b 2o and as well as
nuclear submarines and even they flew
the stretch bombers over the Korean
Peninsula and they practice the even
pumping nuclear bombs on the territory
of the deeper Korea but you're very
practiced the invasion of an airport
only a couple of days ago
invasion of the IB pod there was
military exercise in your country a
couple of days ago or where what we are
talking about is not ordinary military
sizes right we are making an issue of
the aggression I mean the military
exercises for aggression in collusion
which was conducted in collusion with
the foreign forces you know that is why
the proposal I mean the important
proposal made by the National Defense
Commission said that if the what they
called around coordination and
cooperation are so precious and valuable
for the South Korean authorities it
would be better to conduct military
exercises in a secluded secluded land
all in the United States far away from
the territory and land air of deeper
Korea we are not opposing this you know
ordinary you know
village exercises but military sizes to
invade a deeper Korea so there is some
indication that this year America might
not send
b-52 bombers it might not send an
aircraft carrier or a nuclear submarine
if it does to take part in the exercises
if it doesn't send those pieces of
equipment is that acceptable now this
step forward you know we already
received the information they made
already public they're the military
units that are scheduled to participate
in the military joint military exercises
are already allocated the targets the
targets are the main subjects of the DPR
Korea and even what they called around
the landing operation coordinated
Ssangyong if they said the Ssangyong
landing operations purpose is to capture
the capital Pyongyang so this is very
aggressive in nature there is why we
called it military exercises of our
aggression against the DPR Korea and it
is just a pretext for nuclear attack on
the DPR Korea but if you've blamed the
United States as presents for being a
barrier to peace and reunification of
the peninsula these military exercises
are carried out by the Americans and by
the South Koreans which suggests that
there are at least some people in the
south of the peninsula who are opposed
to reunification that is why the
National Defense Commission made a very
important proposal to make a favorable
climate for improved north-south
relations it we it proposed halting all
acts of slandering the other the other
side in this regard we officially
proposed South Korea to stop all actual
you know slandering from the date of
30th that is the day before the new
Lunar New Year and at the same time we
proposed halting all acts of aggression
for securing peace and security on the
Korean Peninsula and number three we
proposed you know to to take a measure
to take a practical measure to prevent
the to prevent the Korean Peninsula to
be inflicted upon you know
by the debilities ask if you're really
serious and you're a diplomat yeah you
have to look at the long game yeah if
you're really serious your turn a blind
eye you will ignore the military
exercises if they go on because of the
greater good in the long term what do
you mean do exercises well you have said
pyongyang has said you will halt acts of
sluggers and military aggression yes but
it seems to me that the condition is
that the military exercises next month
don't go ahead but as a diplomat you
must recognize that the military
exercises do go ahead it might be
worthwhile your country are just
allowing them to go ahead for the long
term good well our important proposal
might made by the National Defense
Commission is not for clad immediate
camouflaged peace initiative it is the
expression of sincerity towards the you
know making the reconciled and
cooperative and he proved the relations
between the North and South you know the
north-south relations is very important
in terms of a you know creating of good
atmosphere and creating a good
situations in Asia and Pacific you know
the when the Nasus relations is bad the
situations in pacific is affected and
the rest of the world that is why the
experts in many countries and now
expressing great concern at the pending
military exercises by joint military
sites by the United States South Korea
codenamed you know you know key resolve
and foal Eagle you know it is they said
the ROM it will bring about only tension
on the Korean Peninsula which is not
favorable for not only the Korean
Peninsula but the Asia Pacific and the
rest of the world and that is why you
know our respect leader in his neo dress
clarify they made appointment made it
click made it clear that it is a high
time to put an end to the confrontation
between the north and south you know and
he's particularly said that in a will to
will join hands with anybody who opted
to keep priority to nation and who
wishes for unification regardless of his
or her past and will strive energetic
whilst will strive more for better
relations between the north and south so
it is it is a high time the South Korea
to stop or to cancel the military
exercises and it is advisable for the
international community to try hard to
prevent the South kind with dangerous
military exercises which is the with
which is no which is no good for anybody
and which is undesired by anybody would
you allow United Nations weapons
inspectors into the country to inspect
your nuclear plant well you know our
transparency you know you should
understand that ROM you know we we have
as I told you our nuclear deterrent is
not to strike the others you know it is
not to strike others it is the means
abou instrument for the prevention of
nuclear war on the Korean Peninsula and
as for the inspection of the nuclear
facilities the plans in the deeper curry
is another question it should it was
discussed in the six-party talks before
but ceasefire talks has stopped to
function so you know
IAEA or international community has no
reason to come to the deeper Korea for
inspection and we have no right and no
obligation to show our nuclear
activities to them just one more
question on relations between North and
South Korea South Korea has proposed a
family reunion yes
probably some points in the middle of
February is that something that North
Korea will accept that something North
Korea will take part in well as a matter
of fact it is the DPR Korea initiative
to hope to arrange the meeting of the
separated families and the relatives the
Central Committee of the Red Cross
Society of the deep hair Korea proposed
to her to arrange that
the Union which was reunion to separate
families which was suspended last year
due to the unfavorable conditions and
situations you know by the united by the
South Korea but we said that it under
the I mean the under the framework all
or in order to implement the practical
measures set forth by the National
Defense Commission through the crucial
proposal Red Cross Society said that we
are we are prepared to arrange they we
propose the South Koreans so Red Cross
Society to arrange the reunion of
separated families and it said that well
the timing I mean the timing would be
the time would be the time after the you
knew in a new year when the cold weather
tolls warm for the elders all right and
[Music]
designated that the place as you know
Congress and Resort which was agreed
upon by the north and south before and
as for the practical and practical and
exact date could be exchanged and
discussed by through in a between the
two sides so I think around you know
your country will be a part of it yeah
they are now working on then you know I
want to move on to this other topics I
want to talk about particularly
something that has been in the news in
this country and elsewhere a lot over
the last couple of months and that is
the execution of Kim jong-un's uncle
mm-hmm Jan song Tek
what did he do wrong well Samson did
allot several crimes you know he he made
the anti-party
anti-government crimes and as well as he
abused his power in hindering the
national economy and I mean the
hindering the efforts of hindering the
efforts for national economy and for
improving the people's living standards
and he made there lots of corruption
life he spent to 4.6 million pounds six
million euro in 2009 all alone but
though he made he made them to demand
those crimes against the government
against the people against the country
so they enlarged the meeting of the
Politburo of the central committee of
the workers party Korea made an issue of
him actually around our party pardoned
him on several occasions when he made
the same you know when he made the
wrongdoings in the past but this time
his crimes is beyond the level you know
it's beyond he's beyond the red red line
and so he was executed so the the
enlarged meeting of the party handed
over to the legal system
so the special military court of the
ministry will in a state security
security put him on the trial he
confessed he you know what he did wrong
and according to the article 60 of the
Criminal Court of the deeper Korea he
was executed how according to the laws
by the you know Criminal Court
he was sentenced today but how was he
executed because there has been okay
some very wild reports that he might
have been fed to the dogs no no you
clear it up how is he executed was he
shot well she was she was shot to death
nice family well the mass media
particularly the South Korean Japanese
mass media which against the deeper
Korea in propaganda spare the subsequent
rumors his families and many people I
executed sort of thing you know this is
the political propaganda by our enemies
so his family have not been active I
don't I I think that's making fabricated
report does not deserve my comment they
are alive he was the one who should be
punishing I know it wasn't dependent I
was not know he was a punished but and
his family is punished or not I don't
know I just wonder third for everything
he did wrong he is your leader Kim Jones
uncle was his uncle he was his mentor
were led to believe she was not mean
what you say about your leaders
authority that you know there's
something South Korea and Japan
described him as a reformist all rigid
or you said you said mental mental
mental sort of thing but he was not that
kind of person it was not that kind of
guy he you know he he he you know he was
of course in a high position but he
abused the power but our punishment you
know is applied to anybody regardless of
is a high official position or low
position Louis said one Louis one and
it's applied at us in a same manner to
anybody it's very extreme punishment now
for those of us living in this country
you've lived in this country for a
number of years it is an extreme form of
punishment where each country has its
own system you know I know the European
Union as well as some European countries
does not have a penalty system death
penalty
they are opposed to but still there are
many countries that that used the death
penalty it's up to them it's all the
same each country has different legal
system and we have a legal system so if
they if the crimes are so high and
treason then she should be punished
regardless of who is and you talk about
it doesn't matter whether you're at the
top of society or at the bottom of
society country yes there is a legal
system to manage yes that legal system
involves sentencing people to labor
camps well those guys made the wrong
against the government you know needs to
be punished but we don't have a labor
camps actually we have education camps
all right it that camps a education
place but the United States and South
Korea Japan and the other Western
countries say that we will labor camps
but that is not true
but you won't allow journalists from
outside to explore the country for
themselves to see whether or not there
are camps or not well now I find it hard
to know how you're expecting the outside
world to believe this we don't have
labor camps
how can he introduced her how can you
allow the Joris to go and see the labor
camps but if a journalist from your
country came to London they could get a
train to Scotland or Wales they could go
where they pleased yes that wouldn't be
the case for me no what I'm saying is
they were armed you know if the
journalists want once wants to conform
what they call to conform or investigate
whether there is a labor camps as
indicated by the others this this is not
the way of for journalists to come to
come and visit you know journalists as
you know is the pioneers in promoting
the understanding between the two
countries by showing what is going on
there and what is it going on there here
and there right so it is not
more it is not moral for journalists to
to use you know to serve as you know
political political purpose one man who
is in your G dish has been through your
judicial system is in prison at the
moment in your country is the American
can't buy okay yeah in East Bay yes
there was a press conference very
recently that he was at is that a step
towards his freedom well you know he he
called himself Paul for press conference
and he said that this in recent days
misinformation are spread regarding with
regard with we God in regard with him
you know he said that some mass media
linked him saying that in tip her career
is human rights you know abuser and can
spare was miss of you and be abused and
hard treated by the DPRK so he called
for the conference and made it correct
she said that you know the Vice
President of the United States said he
is not you know he's not made a crime
obviously if and he's not guilty and his
own sister also said he's not guilty he
is not guilty so he said that he already
informed the government of the United
States and his family that he did
something wrong you know he made a crime
so against deeper Korea but he is now
you know receiving fair treatment though
he spent 15 months in Pyongyang and when
he is sick he received the medical
treatment and you know he was given an
access to Swiss Embassy which represents
the United States on a consular issue he
said this is normal normal going on but
if the mass media and some countries
spreading such kind of a misinformation
it would be e to make him more difficult
he said that so he said please come down
you know I'm okay you know
I'm a criminal I'm serving but I said he
pleaded for or efforts will he be more
efforts by the government of the United
States and his family for his release
but if when when you asked whether he's
released or not he'll be released when
he finished his reserve he was sentenced
to 15 years of hard labor you know so
when he finished his term according to
the law why there's no reason why not
there is no reason not to release him so
he's doing hard labor not really hard
labor he received his receiving wrong
you know medical medical treatment now
but he was sentenced 15 years hard labor
well yes like a labor camp yes not
merely labor camp you don't have labor
camp he was sentenced to hard labor hard
labor of course but you know you know I
I don't know the level of the house
would extent or level of the hard labor
what what the harder labor is about but
you know how the labor not okay he
played order or live he pleaded for his
country to do more to secure his release
if he said that would suggest yeah that
there is a possibility he could be
released early before his 15 years
mm-hmm and a suggestion that perhaps
your country is open to some negotiation
well you know legal system you know I I
cannot say about legal system I cannot
interfere in the you know legal system
when the law or when they were
adjustment is done then it's done but
sometimes there's occasions for pardon
but I don't know and I don't I cannot
predict that Kenneth BAE will be
pardoned or not he should be if he
should finish his term that is all
according to the crimes you know corners
with the crimes what he made against the
deep her career just finally I want to
return to the open letter
and to the New Year's address which
calls for peace on the peninsula but of
course signs of aggression to Holt can
you put a time scale on any of this can
you suggest how long it might take for
reunification in your eyes or perhaps
peace in other people's eyes where it is
the consistent the policy of the
government of DPR Korea you know to
improve the inter-korean relations and
to develop the you know reconciliation
and cooperative cooperation between the
North and South well
when the whole Korean Peninsula whether
they are in the north and south formally
United in terms of wishing for
reunification and striving for all the
reunification the day of reunification
will come all here I think so for this
run you know you know the the proposal
the important proposal made by the
National Defense Commission is very
important in that in that regard you
know our our respected leader master Kim
ji-woon made a bold proposal that will
join hands with anyone who opted if I
repeat with will join hands with anyone
who opt to give a priority to the nation
and who wishes for reunification
regardless of the past or his whole past
you know this is very important you know
if all the coronation is united
reconcile cooperated you know then the
reunification would come you know
earlier you know as a matter of fact you
know we have the
20 declaration between the north and
south as you know June 16 2010 and
October 4 joint declaration between the
North and South which was made at the
summit level between the two sides it
shows the way and means for national
reunification so this is the standpoint
I mean that this this is the principles
this is the banner of reunification for
North and South to follow and finally if
the military exercises go ahead with the
United States and South Korea yes with
your country retaliate well as I told
you you know since our National Defense
Commission made very important proposals
to hold all acts of military actions
hostile against the other it's very
important to implement that then right
so I don't I don't think you know it is
natural to predict what the consequences
would be you know but you've said that
you want to hold for military action so
the inference from that what I would
learn from that is that even if the
exercises go ahead well you know what
you know you know we I mean the the
National Defense Commission made a
strong you know an important proposals
and following that the National Defense
Commission sent to open letter again
urging the South Korea to stop all the
acts of slandering to stop all acts of a
military hostile military action so let
us see what they are what they way to
respond so before they respond you know
you know of course their initial
response is very negative but let us
wait and see and I cannot say here the
consequences are not
I mean that consequences of military
actions you know go ahead for your head
you know